I know you're gonna be blown away by this,
but we're going to have to talk about free
speech today.
It'd be nice if a week would pass by when
we didn't have to talk about a threat to freedom
of speech, but it seems almost every day there
is a new outrage on the horizon aimed at chipping
away our right to free expression.
There are three specific happenings right
now that I want to focus on, in no particular
order.
First, there's the ongoing saga of Bret Weinstein
at Evergreen University in Washington.
In case you missed our livestream with Bret
last week, he is being attacked by being called
a racist and a bigot for opposing a day in
which white students wouldn't be welcome on
campus.
Bret claimed the revised Day of Absence on
campus based on racial segregation was not
just racist and bigoted, but was the complete
reverse of what the day was supposed to stand
for.
Bret has been a progressive his whole life,
but even he is not immune to the toxic ideology
of Leftism, which rates victimhood as virtue
and will swallow anyone who dares deviate
from it's authoritarian rule.
The campus was closed due to threats of violence
and even now Bret is getting no backing from
the administration, which appears to be bending
to the demands of the crazed mob.
Even worse, mainstream media is basically
all but ignoring this story because it so
shatters the regressive ideology.
Mainstream, left leaning outlets don't want
to touch this story because they don't want
to be tarred the same way Bret is.
Thus, almost all the coverage of the Evergreen
story has been from right leaning websites.
Bret has done three live interviews, one right
here, one on Joe Rogan's podcast and one with
Tucker Carlson on Fox News.
He hasn't been invited on CNN, MSNBC or NPR
and none of those outlets have even written
a piece on the story.
When you hear trust in mainstream media is
at an all time-low, it's reasons like ignoring
hugely relevant stories that go against their
narrative that are part of the reason.
The next story of the last few days was the
outrage over Kathy Griffin's ISIS inspired
photos holding up President Trump's decapitated,
bloody head.
First off, on the free speech front, I fully
support Kathy's right to take these pictures
and make art as she sees fit.
I don't think these photos are a direct call
to violence, which would be a crime, and the
pictures should be seen through the lense
that she is a comedian and a provocateur,
regardless of whether you think the images
are in poor taste or just outright awful.
So, while it is 100% in her right to make
the images, it is also 100% in CNN's right,
as her employer to fire her if they see it
fit.
Now interestingly, in this case, it was the
right calling for CNN to fire Griffin and
it was the Left that was defending her, though
in this case less people came to her defense
than usual.
While this is a flip on the script of the
last few years, it's important to remember
it seems people only hold their own values
when it's easy to do so.
Just imagine if it had been a conservative
comedian like Tim Allen holding up a severed
head of President Obama.
The Left would've been demanding his show
be cancelled and the right would've been defending
him.
Ironically, Tim Allen's highly rated show
was cancelled a few weeks ago and many people
think it is at least partially because he's
been outspoken about being a conservative
in Hollywood.
The final story I want to touch on is the
outrage over Bill Maher using the N word on
Real Time last Friday.
I can't even repeat what Bill Maher said,
because even just by quoting him I'll end
up in hot water, which shows you how insane
the language police have gotten.
Basically he made a joke using the N word,
and all hell broke loose.
To be clear, he didn't use the N word to describe
anyone in particular or take a racist position,
it was a line, that I suspect was prepackaged
to illicit a reaction from the crowd.
It not only elicited a reaction from the crowd
but also the bigoteer brigade which immediately
began calling for his firing from HBO.
I even saw comedians I know calling for him
to be fired over a joke.
This is Bill Maher, who many of you who lean
right absolutely hate, and now the Left was
doing your job of trying to destroy him.
Sadly the Left has been coming for Bill for
a long time mainly because he isn't afraid
of talking about radical Islam, which has
set him apart from most on the Left.
I know a little something about that myself.
HBO took the joke out of repeats of the show
and so far has withstood calls to fire him
and Maher even apologized, something he has
chastized others for doing in the past.
Senator Al Franken cancelled an appearance
on Real Time for this week, despite being
a friend of Bill and the show for years.
I've invited Senator Franken on the show to
discuss, but I won't hold my breath.
So there you have it.
A professor bullied off campus by threats
of violence for fighting against racism.
A comedian fired for a tasteless gag and another
comic under the threat of firing for a joke.
None of these are threats to the first amendment,
which as you know is the government coming
for speech, but all add up the chill factor
around freedom of expression that I've been
talking about for quite some time.
If you were a professor would you be willing
to explore a controversial idea with students
after what's happened to Bret?
If you were an artist would you be willing
to paint a controversial painting after what's
happened to Kathy?
And if you were a comic would you be willing
to tell an offensive joke after what's happening
to Bill?
If you answered no to any of these then you
must acknowledge that the threat to free expression
is real.
Don't like Bret?
Don't take his class.
Think Kathy is crass, watch something else
on New Years.
Don't think Bill is funny?
Change the channel.
But whatever you do, keep watching The Rubin
Report, because we've got Jason Whitlock from
Fox Sports 1 on the show this week.
He was in his own outrageapalooza last week
with calls for him to be fired too, but I'll
save that for our chat.